So I think that is a clever idea, random research.
That was one of the ways that we got unstuck
when we were in local optima when we were doing
optimization. Maybe this will also come in handy, in this setting.
>> Yeah I like the idea because I came up with it but I can
see a couple, you know, but I can see a couple of problems with it.
>> But well you can't see a problem with it yet because
it's not even clear what you meant. Or maybe that's the first problem.
>> Well it was clear what I meant in my head,
now if you're going to want my mouth to understand what my head
meant, well then your just asking for too much, so I really kind
of meant, random restarts where you just kind of start it over,
over, over, and over again, the problem with that, the problem with that
is, it's already going to take a long time, you know, infinity
to get to a good answer. And we thought we might have this
issue with randomized optimization, certainly this
is going to be a problem here,
but it still feels like there's something we could do with the randomness
idea that would help us to overcome this problem with
using what we know. And only using what we know.
>> Alright, alright, so I, I like that direction. So let's think a little
bit about what that could mean. So random restarts was one idea that we had
when we were talking in optimization about
getting unstuck, which is, let yourself get
stuck, and then once you realize you're
stuck, throw everything out and start over again.
>> Right.
>> And you're right. That's going to end up being really slow, but we
had a different way of Of using randomness
to get unstuck. In, for example, algorithms like
>> Simulating annealing
>> That's what I was thinking about. Yeah, so
Simulating annealing. The idea is Simulating annealing is
that you tend to, you take up hill steps. But
occassionally, you're willing to take a random down hill step.
>> Right.
>> So, it's kind of this mixture
of choosing randomly. And using what you know,
what seems to be the best. Right, and so, yeah,
yeah, I can see that. So then the random restarts thing
kind of works if instead of it being a random restart,
it's, it's just a random action every once in a while.
>> Yeah, excellent alright. So simulated annealing like-approach
says we're going to take a random action sometimes.
So then our exploration policy, our approximate policy,
is going to be. To, we're in state s.
Figure out the best action in that state according to our estimate
and take that with probability I don't know. let's say one minus epsilon.
>> Mm-hm.
>> In otherwise take a random action and see what happens.
>> I have a probability of epsilon. Yeah that's whats left over so.
>> Right so that's why you had one minus
epsilon because you want epsilon to be small. So epsilon
is going to be. So every once in a while
you will randomly act, oh and then that'll, that'll solve
the sim annealing problem. Or do what sim annealing helps you with
by just taking a random action in what looks like a bad direction,
comparatively, sometimes. But it also means that you get to explore the whole
space. And so you have a chance of actually learning the true Q.
>> Exactly. So, and yet most of the time,
you know, we're spending, assuming Epsilon is small, we're
spending a lot of our time taking good actions,
or actions that we think are good. But we're always
holding out some probability of taking other
actions to help us improve our Q hat.
>> Mm, so if you do that infinitely long, and you've, this will, so this will
let you visit SA. An infinite number of
times, as long as epsilon is greater than zero.
>> That's right and that the mdp is connected, right?
So, there could be state action pairs, that just can't ever
be reached, in which case you won't reach them. But that's
okay, because since you can't reach them, they really don't matter.
>> Yeah, they sort of don't exist.
>> Exactly. Alright so let's let's focus in on this a
little bit more because I think that this is now the
first idea that we've had for choosing actions that has the
property that it will learn and it will use what it learns.
>> Mm, I like that.